after fans can't wait to see actors here
Oh fine Tiffin and Josephine Langford
portrayed the iconic characters Hardin
Scott and Tessa yang this movie has been
a long time coming so we thought it
would be fun to take a look at some of
the cutest behind-the-scenes moments the
film has to offer the after cast is so
close they might as well be family and
we've got the pics to prove it
you could draw me to any death you could
throw me to anything I've most avoided
euro fine Tiffin has come a long way
from playing the 11-year old version of
Tom Riddle and Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince the English actor is
only 21 years old and has already
managed to make a name for himself his
glow-up happened quickly and now that
he's been cast as Hardin Scott he's on
everyone's radar and the same can be
said about actress Josephine Langford
who plays Hardin's on-screen lover Tessa
now Before we jump into some adorable
behind-the-scenes pictures and videos
let's take a look at some of the
trailers cutest moments are we the only
ones losing it over the way Hardin looks
at Tessa yeah we didn't think so both
the official trailer and the teaser
trailer are jam-packed with heated
scenes and tender moments and there's
one joke that we couldn't help but laugh
at did you hear Tessa's giggle yeah the
girl is swooning although many of us
already know that Hardin in Tessa's
relationship is going to be a bumpy ride
there are some cute moments that remind
us why they're together in the first
place besides you know what they say
couples who read together stay together
you could draw me to any death you could
throw me to anything I have most avoided
there are so many awesome scenes to
choose from but if we had to pick a
favorite it would be this one because
well the look they share screams fatal
attraction while promising drama at
every turn the trailer confirms what
after fans already know this movie is
going to be wild actors know all too
well that they owe a portion of their
success to their buzzing fans knowing
this hero didn't waste much time before
thanking his followers
thank you so much we're so used to
seeing Hiro looking super serious behind
the camera that it's nice to see him
cracking a joke or two with his co-star
Josephine just look how easy it is for
Josephine to get hiro to crack a smile
it makes the world go round
yes Wow it's nice to know that someone
as famous as Hiro has positive views
when it comes to love
after writer Anna Todd grew especially
close to Josephine which led her to post
this picture it's normal for actors to
become super close while on set but we
didn't expect the cast to become a
family overnight still the actors had to
travel to complete the movie and this
brought them all the way to Paris if
this isn't the best family vacation
picture of all time we don't know what
is but the fun didn't stop there in fact
the cast also went to Rome where they
became closer than ever
here we see Anna leaning her head on
Hiro's shoulder the actors look
comfortable and happy in their skin move
over Bella and Edward there's a new
tumultuous couple in town and they just
might get the dramatic Twilight couple a
run for their money on August 21st 2018
the after cast group together to get
thanks to their fans during a book
signing dr. Samuel Larson and Shane Paul
Magee who play characters dead Evans and
Landon Gibson respectively
we're also present for the book signings
Anna Todd posted this pic on her
Instagram page and we're totally diggin
the group's dynamic it's clear that
they're having an awesome time both on
and off the after set but it's safe to
say that this lively cast has fun
wherever they go during the after la
première hero and josephine posed with
producer jennifer give go and co-star
Khadija read thunder who plays the role
of Steph Jones it's clear that these
celebs have become fast friends still we
can't help but these our eyes on hero
Josephine who are arguably one of the
best on-screen couples we've yet to see
this handsome pair is the real OTP leave
a red heart in the comments if you agree
we just love Josephine's red carpet look
and our suit looks even nicer when
photographed next to actress Pia Mia
flashy yellow two-piece Pia Mia portrays
Tristan in the after franchise and we're
happy to see that Josephine and Pia
are nothing short of two peas in a pod
despite having up last while onset of
the after movie filming the romantic
dramedy did have its fair share of
challenges during an interview with ET
hero and josephine came clean about what
really happened during their steamy lake
scenes don't tell Joe because I just
kind of assumed that you wouldn't want
to know there's a snake and more that we
get into light it seems to say that
nothing ruins a romantic moment more
than a lake snake on Rogue anyone with
two eyes can see that Josephine Langford
is downright gorgeous but despite being
a relatively new actor there's something
about her that is oh so familiar alright
that's what it is
she's a carbon copy of Riverdale's Betty
Cooper who is portrayed by actress Lilly
Reinhardt we mean just look at them
they're basically the same person
filming a movie is a whole lot of fun
but it's also very tiring
knowing this many actors choose to lay
low while off-duty but this wasn't the
case for hero Samuel Sheen and fellow
actor Swann's Hamill who plays Landon
Gibson these four friends took advantage
of their night off and enjoyed a night
out on the town from the looks of things
these four amigos have formed an
unbreakable bond but when going out
isn't an option the gang can always kick
back listen to music and goof around
okay we take it back
only in Anna Sarkis seems to be enjoying
the music we mean did you see how a
serious hero looked if we didn't know
any better we'd say hero isn't a fan of
the classics or perhaps hero likes to
jam to a different genre music there you
go heroes on a roll be sure to let us
know which after character is your
favorite in the comments below give this
video a big thumbs up if you're excited
to watch the after movie and be sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching we'll
catch you next time
[Music]